oh yeah yeah yeah yeah Weedon boys
[Music]
what's up guys that's a little bit of
Wiz Kalifa bringing us in here it's it's
1:00 a.m. it is it is Monday morning
1:00 a.m.
Golden Globes just went down this is
this past weekend man I'm gonna get into
it I'm gonna get into a little bit
everything I'm gonna talk about a sleepy
ubirr driver who fell asleep at the
wheel
who was gonna fall asleep at the wheel
so he let his passenger drive he falls
asleep in the back seat and next thing
you know he wakes up and he's in a
high-speed chase now he's suing uber I
got a cup of hot coffee right here I got
uh I got uh what else we'll talk I'll
check in had a little bit of adult sex
you know had some adult sex this uh this
weekend you know doing that you know um
so that was interesting what else
happened man had some great comedy sets
Larry David was at the Laugh Factory the
other night we'll talk about the Golden
Globes a little bit and and what else
man the guy the gun they had the gunman
in Fort Lauderdale jeez I fly in and out
of there man I was that was nuts but but
right now we're right here it's uh it's
it's it's us man this past weekend ooh
yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's Wiz Khalifa Whedon boys man I'm
amazed that guy's always hi Wiz khlifa
always hi I don't know how they do it
you know black guys so good at smoking
weed so much better I feel like my black
friends always they can get high do
regular life I get high not doing
regular life man incapacitated in high
school I remember I would go out with my
friends I get high I would lay in the
car all night we would go to parties I
would be in the car asleep
my big thing used to be to urinate in
people's trunks or in like this one guy
in high school his dad used to sell
sunglasses and I would always urinate on
all of his samples huh
god I feel bad about that yeah I would
urinate on the dad samples I don't know
what was I'm a nice to urinate on
everything but I'm feeling better this
week last week I had that flu that's a
stomach virus that's gone out of my
system so that feels good if you're sick
man hold it together hold it together
sue whoever gave it to you sue whoever
gave it to you yeah so let's crack right
into it man yeah this news story
unbelievable to me sleepy uber driver
suing everyone okay there's a guy a
driver he fell asleep he was falling
asleep at the wheel so we let he let his
passenger drive he asked him to drive it
was a long trip out of New York and then
the driver Robinson was the guy's name
woke somewhere around Binghamton New
York to find his good-samaritan
passenger Carlos 20 speeding on
Interstate 81 Robinson begged his
passenger to pull over but Carlos
responded the police are chasing us
ah-hoo for I don't even know where to
what kind of uber driver I guess you get
tired yeah hey you want to take the
wheel that's that's teamwork actually
I'm it's a little bit of teamwork but
that's
that's alarming to me you know I think
at that point you pull over and you let
the guy get another rubra if you can't
handle the game you know I don't you're
not a real uber driver if you can't
handle the responsibility you know a
boxer isn't in the middle of his
fighting is like I you know I'm just
kind of not doing well I'm not winning
why don't we let us somebody else who
feels like fighting right now fight you
don't do that so this is unbelievable to
me the car was completely totaled the
Hyundai Sonata they totaled the car
smashed into a guardrail in Colesville
New York Robinson lost his driver job
Carlos was charged with unlawfully
fleeing a police officer and and there
you go that's it so if you having a
shitty Monday Lisa's not that shitty huh
at least you're not either one of those
guys you know I remember in uh in I used
to fall asleep at the wheel all the time
I don't know what I think i mighta beat
narcolepsy at some point because when I
was um I remember when I was a student
driver I had to drive somewhere and at
some point I just told the dude bro I'm
falling asleep he's like it's 4:00 in
the afternoon I'm like yeah well when
naptime calls bro you know dormir say
you know it's time for daddy to do air
me and he let me rest in the backseat he
took me home I didn't fail I'm still
driving today
another time I fell asleep at a
stoplight Madisonville Louisiana a cop
wakes me up he goes did you call in
report about two wolves fighting in the
street and I was back I mean I was you
know uh I was just baffle I'm like I
know I you know I didn't I didn't do
that I was bummed that I missed that you
know I fell asleep I fell asleep at the
wheel dude I mean according to somebody
who called the police two wolves were
fighting wolves I never saw a wolf in
Louisiana ever but somebody called him
in to the police - wolves fighting in an
intersection unbelievable man so here we
are Bros this is it it's Monday morning
trying to
what's going on this past weekend was
good man it was good
spend some time with friends I'll give
you a little emotional update I'm
feeling pretty good
I think I'm thirty what am i some so
many days off of the pornography let me
check in right here and see I'm a decent
amount of days off the pornography Ike
I'm a little porn o'clock on my phone I
am 33 days pornography for free feeling
good feeling feeling heavy and the kak
you know it's coming in it's coming in
because you get desensitized you get
desensitized about the pornography man I
was you know when I wasn't like a crazy
Pope but I just I think just like any
other dude you know you come home at
night you're single maybe it's happened
it's the Internet the Internet's there
it's waiting for you it's waiting for
anything you want to get nasty naughty
you want to gamble you want to bet on
hookers you want to do whatever you want
the internet so I'm off of that man I'm
off of that 33 days and feeling pretty
good man I'm feeling pretty heavy in the
heavy in the [__] these days fired up
you know I don't know why I got into
porn I when I think about it I remember
the first time I ever saw any
pornographer my brother
I remember in his closet I found some
pornography magazines and uh and some
peach Alizee I was a liqueur and next
nine minutes later bro I was uh I was
drunk and exhausted that's all I
remember dude spraying out like a young
buck and that's really I guess where I
started any experience with pornography
and then you know when you don't you're
not uh in a relationship or something
you kind of stick with it I guess here
and there I don't know but I'm off it
feels good if you're having an issue
with it man take a break you know take a
break bro let your brain let your
imagination key up a little bit let your
imagination fire up I got some coffee
I'm gonna throw some date at you really
quick February 26 through 29th I'm
coming to Virginia Beach funnybone I'll
be at the Schomburg improv in Chicago
every 2nd through the 4th last time I
was there I saw mr. T preach at a church
I pity the fool who don't find me at the
Comedy Works South in Denver the 23rd
through the 26th of February dude I did
an open mic tonight stop by The Improv
to pick up some footage from my show the
other night where I headlined the show
and they had open mic going on there was
like 40 young comics in there that
drawing names out of a hat and uh Jamie
and Paige the people who run the place
over at the comedy at The Improv they're
like you want to go up and I was like no
way I was so nervous I mean I just took
me back to whenever I first started
comedy and I actually first did my first
set on that very stage at The Improv but
I was so nervous man so I sat there for
about 15 minutes and watch the young
guys do it and then I got up I got up
tried some new bits some new thoughts
what else my buddy got bit by a gay guy
my buddy got bit by a gay guy dude so I
guess it's a public service announcement
up there by La Brea and uh La Brea
Boulevard and in Santa Monica Boulevard
Filipino dude huge legs big quads open
mouth if you see that dude you know he's
out there bit my buddy good he got bit
by a gay guy so we'll see what happens
man we'll see how that shakes out Oh
what else sleepy uber driver reminded me
of a time I went to school in Charleston
South Carolina and I used to spend some
time of an air actually hitchhiked up
there chasing a girl not like a stalker
chasing a girl but you know I was in
love I was in young love my girlfriend
had broken up with me so I knew she was
there and I hitchhiked I was at a
sailing regatta in Biloxi Mississippi
some people said they lives in
Charleston I said you got an extra seat
and 14 hour car ride later and a
suburban brother
showed up middle of the night I remember
I even why this is stalkery now now that
I'm reciting it obviously I walk to my
girlfriend where I knew she lived
because we've been corresponding via
mail
ah those are the days they'd love
letters corresponding being I walked to
where she lived
it's like 2:00 in the morning because we
got him really late and I'm standing out
on her porch had a cat there I'm petting
this cat and it hit me like dude you
gotta you need to get your act together
cuz you this girl doesn't know you're
here you're standing on her porch but
petting a cat you don't even know if
it's her cat and she didn't like me
anymore so that was kind of a wake-up
call that was a little bit alarming you
know so if you ever been in that
scenario I feel it I feel you you know I
feel yeah I feel how it can happen it
can happen bro we all got a little
stalker in us you ever done some stalker
stuff ever done some stalker stuff let
me know man
so this podcast I'm putting it out this
past weekend it's just you know it's
developmental last week it people told
me the audio the volume is too low try
to turn the volume up okay so I'm trying
that what else they told me to stick
with it so I'm trying that we're gonna
get to a point where we're gonna have
video as well we're gonna maybe some
call ins
maybe some gas or just starting out so
if you have any thoughts ideas whatever
you whatever let me know you know I
don't know how to give better without
help you know that's where I'm at in my
life the only way I'm gonna get better
is if people help me so if you got some
thoughts
throw on my way Golden Globes were on I
watched the intro I watched some
sporadic spots throughout it the intro
was awesome I thought it was exciting I
thought Jimmy Fallon did a good job they
the big thing on the Internet is the
Meryl Streep speech about Trump and
about the you know diversity and this
and that I personally I'm oh I'm just
sick of hot I mean this was you know a
bunch of well off well to do people
really patna each other on the back you
know in this beautiful event at the
Beverly Hilton
and uh you know I don't want to hear
about that stuff I don't want to hear
about it I'm honestly kind of sick of
everybody just like we get it like if
you're the guy you did where the lady
you wanted in and when we get it but
well you know just there's bigger issues
there's real issues that people are
facing you know I mean it's not like
trumps blown up the White House or but
you know so then they keep bringing up
all this Russia stuff [__] Russia dude
Russia was they were giving out dirty
water at the Olympics that seems like
more of an issue you know that seems
like more of an issue to me but no
people want to you know mainstream media
it's just bizarre it's baffling to me I
was happy to see the hate crime that
people took labeled that as a hate crime
that they had the for they had the for
people beating up the [__] kid or
the sorry mentally challenged kid I
don't want to say [__] that is yeah
that that that that I agree with that
needs to go sometimes beating up the
mentally challenged kid I was gross man
I was gross and uh and it's tough
because they don't want to label you
know they don't want to label a hate
crime then it can be against white
people but it can you know and so I
think it's nice to see that that they
were at a place of equality where where
anybody can be a victim of a hate crime
bro that really really uh I really felt
that that was it needed to be man it's
gross that kind of stuff grow I mean you
know I don't know how people get so
broke a minute they can't put it
together you know they can't put it
together I don't know
[__] if I know dude I'm listening to Wiz
Khalifa it's 1:00 a.m. I'm drinking
coffee you know what am I even doing
what am I even doing uh had some adult
sex this weekend man had some sex bro
and it was chill dude you know it was
chill uh uh
I haven't really been engaged in a lot
of sexual activity because I'm really
just kind of keeping it chill trying to
get my feelings in order you know
because I wanna you know I wanna you
know I'd like to have a wife and a
family and that sort of thing so you got
to really at a certain point wrangle
your desires in because you can't be
just spraying out everywhere across town
if you want to you know really kind of
care about somebody who have some
feelings so I think it was a pretty
decent practice man I got some sexual
anxiety sometimes but I think I really
gave it a good run you know two
consenting adults doing some adult sex
so I feel like it was good man
you know just basic sexual positions
nothing really Randy you know I've had a
crazy kind of sexual past at times lost
my virginity behind a bowling alley down
there in Louisiana while some kids were
throwing rocks at us so I don't know I
mean that was that's a hell of a way to
start off catching some trim you know
yeah some kids were throwing rocks at us
we were doing stand-up sex behind a
bowling alley shady it was in the shady
ball it was the only bowling alley we
had every bowling alleys pretty Shady I
think especially every small town
bowling alley but they and they didn't
have a really good menu inside I
remember but uh yeah said so a you know
very middle-eastern almost you know
people dodging rocks and trying to
maintain an erection at the same time
that was my out Diderot you know as far
as I'm concerned growing up brother that
was my idea ah dude what else had some
other crazy experiences over the years
I'm trying to think what pops or not I
got a actually got a blow job over there
in Pittsburgh behind the giant eagle
grocery only [__] I ever got pinkeye
from I don't know how I got it but I'll
never forget that
never forget that man what else what
else happened this past weekend uh I got
nervous man I got nervous I did a set at
the laughs actually the night Larry
David is sitting there and I can see his
silhouette the white hair the Bernie
Sanders just vibe you know and I'm
performing and I'm trying to do my best
and I don't know he'd been there for a
while it was late when I got onstage
about 12:30 a.m. so and at some point I
think towards the towards the probably
75% of my said he got up in
I don't know if he left or he had a date
or say could've been his wife I don't
know what his scenario was but he left
so uh I don't know and that that stuff
rides on you you know when you're
performing you're like did he leave
because of me
did he was he already gonna leave was he
you know so but it was cool cool to see
him at the club everybody's pretty
excited I've never seen him at a comedy
club before what else got to see Bill
burr perform this weekend awesome always
phenomenal and it was just a great
weekend man it was a great weekend
let me think about what else happened oh
how symmetrical is everybody at the
Golden Globes you see it look at all the
face every symmetry that's what you need
if you want to make it in Hollywood look
at your faces it's symmetrical
not mine do my nose is a little off one
of my nostrils a little bigger another
one of my ears I think might be kind of
a dangler you know I think my eyes one
of them kind of goes a little bit of a
different direction dude not symmetrical
no I don't know what grade I would get
on my face man I don't know I know I'm
about 1/8 looks wise I'm about 1/8 if I
take care of my teeth
you know I'm 1/8 I'm 1/8 and I'm ok with
that I feel like I try to live in
reality special when it comes to my
looks man I mean especially growing up I
didn't I hated the way that I look
growing up man I had I had these big I
just huge spaces in my teeth and it just
made me feel I don't know I was always
embarrassed I had the worst acne in
junior high school I mean I had hey I
like if I smile big like a pimple would
burst I just had all these just pockets
to just see them and just whatever gets
in your face just just disenchantment
just flying out of my pores and you're
going through those weird years to
around puberty when you're when you're
going through a pair billion-year you
got a you ah there's like you could grow
like two inches in a week you know so
next thing you know you're next real
long and you're
shirt that fit on Monday doesn't fit on
Saturday you know you got your half your
friends look like velociraptors like
there's just some weird times in there
when you're going through puberty but I
had a yeah it's some severe acne hated
the way that I looked man I think I'm
getting better with it now as I get
older because you start to realize that
you just stuck with how you look you
know I mean unless you want to get
plastic surgery which is pretty popular
out here and everywhere I guess these
days I remember in sixth seventh grade
they had two girls we had these groups
in our in our school and two girls got
nose jobs and they were both sitting at
my group table in this art class and uh
and they both came back I think from
Christmas break with like these you know
bandages on their nose and I just
thought it was like wow like you know
that's a real thing people can really
get it you know I didn't know that
because I grew up in a mother town that
I really grew up in like if you had a
deficiency or you know a facial
malfunction or whatever that's where you
were you know there wasn't I mean I
remember this one dude he broke his this
is dude was like an adult but he broke
his clavicle or something and uh they
just trying to fixed it right there you
know and just his shirt just never fit
right again he was always that dude
whose shirt never fit right you know cuz
one of his he was kind of missing a
shoulder they just didn't set it back
correctly and uh you just I don't know
bizarre looking another dude I remember
to do was an Elvis impersonator in our
town like we needed a [__] Elvis you
know we had 2,000 people in town bro we
don't need an Elvis dude we need gas
money and we need ideas okay you're an
alcoholic brother but he was an Elvis
impersonator in my old neighborhood and
but he was nervous from personal
interaction when I think about it not
really by nature or not by nurture but
by nature one of the other what happened
was he had broken his hip I don't know
if I told you guys this story he broken
his hip and there to save money they
said his leg is there his leg like
around the top may be broken a bone in
his thigh could be a femur
and to save money they set it and cement
so and it healed up fine but when they
broke the cast off they broke up with a
sledgehammer Reeb rope his leg and hip
in about nine places so after that he
always had this little wobble a little
tick-tock in him and uh and he went into
Elvis impersonation right after that you
know cuz he had that hip sway just built
in you know lean with it rock with it
lean with it rock with it so you know
what I'm saying bro yeah yeah yeah yeah
small town Elvis impersonation man what
else the limited I just heard that the
limited that clothing company shut down
bro dude I grew up the limited they had
a partner store limited with what a
ladies went bro and if you would all the
ladies were limited you know if you had
a little bit of Dimes he had a little
dime in your pocket if your mother had a
little bit of cash she got something
from the limited man that was the first
fancy store ever around and they had a
men's store called structure anybody
ever wear that structure clothing man
that [__] was fresh did I'm where we
used to go camp out the mall now the
mall by me was about how about 17 miles
away so we would go on Friday go to the
mall Friday night then we would camp out
outside just in tents so we could go to
the mall again on Saturday dude we're
back hot topic man that was a good time
dude if we just sleep in tents outside
and uh just to be at the mall man and
they had structure you know but the
funny thing was at Christmas everybody
would they only had about five different
styles in there so everybody you come
back from Christmas break and you'd have
nine dudes all wearing the same shirt
you know so everybody all of a sudden
everybody was just wearing the same [__]
but that would those are the days man
that's how it was that's how it was
and out going to the mall what else man
this duty shot the guy the guy who shot
up the airport the baggage claim god man
oh I always wonder what I would do in
this situation I was watching one of the
videos some lady hid in front of
something like the guy shooting if you
seen the video on CNN she hid in front
of one of the smart cart things Jesus
like hopefully I'd have you know and I
know your your you know your overcome by
the circumstances but hopefully I have a
little more gravitas to hide behind
something you know I don't mean getting
your bags it's frustrating but that dude
really I mean that's set off man come on
and he had a gun apparently they do to
win crate you know that he went into and
alaskey been in the military and the FBI
are at some checkpoint or some
appointment he'd had to check in for
they taking his gun from him he said you
can't have a gun anymore because of his
mental condition but then a month later
they gave it back to him for some reason
and that was the gun he used I wasn't
going to used oh that was the gonna use
man you know I I just I'm okay with
people having guns I'm okay with it you
know but they should have us they should
have a big black lady's in charge of all
the guns I want a bit a real black woman
in charge of all the guns cuz those
ladies don't take any [__] you know
oh you ain't getting a gun boo you ain't
getting a gun that's what I want dude
because you know that not if that's what
they need they need somebody you should
have to really look somebody in the eyes
before you get a gun dude and nobody
takes no [__] or can read no
[__] like a strong black woman man
that's what I think dude that's what I
think brah that's what I think what else
man watch the football I watch the
football I can easy games everybody the
team's always everybody thought was
gonna win I can't wait did win this past
weekend I dude I can't wait for the
Steve
in Kansas City that's gonna be a game
that's gonna be a game man that's gonna
be a game what else happened this
weekend trying to think of really what
occurred man nothing you know nothing
crazy exciting went down I guess you
know we did the adult sex it was good
but at a certain point I'm kind of like
you know banging isn't like that my
favorite pastime like some dudes are
just trying to get you know just chase
some trim all the time I'm kind of I'm
okay with it you know you get a little
bit of trim here you get a little bit of
trim there but it's not you know I'm not
addicted to it like some kind of you
know crate you know and after your
banging for a little bit it's kind of
like okay you know we get it nobody's
gonna win a prize really you know you
hope everybody gets off and that's kind
of a deal so you know I wish there was
more to it sometimes like you really got
it you know like everybody want a bag a
[__] fatty or everybody you know you got
a prize or you bang so hard that you
know you know like a gumball popped out
of your lady's mouth or something like
that I wish some of those was more to it
sometimes just a bang bang bang bang
it's like how many different ways can I
do this I don't know maybe something's
wrong I'm saying this if I'm saying that
there's something wrong with second
maybe something wrong with me all along
I don't know bro but it was good man it
was nice to you know just be involved
just feel some sensuality you know and I
feel like staying off the pornography
that's really coming back into my bones
coming back into my soul man because
that pornography really get you man
because you can get down them rabbit
holes what else man that's pretty much
it dude that's it really I think um but
we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna get
the podcast better we're gonna give
video we're gonna get you know different
stuff going on I'm open to any
suggestions any thoughts any ideas if
you have any questions you want to
answer it on the next one post them post
them wherever this wherever you are
seeing this or reading this Twitter
Facebook YouTube post them up
get to them you know I'll put them in
let's get it you know get some get some
conversation get some conversation going
anything else crazy didn't happen ooh I
got Invisalign went to the dentist you
know Invisalign I got the braces I was
talking about when I was younger I had
you know just just a fantastic mouth and
the crazy part is I kind of wish I had
my old teeth now while I have more you
know confidence as an adult I wish I had
my original grille because you know they
were now would really kind of set me
apart it's more unique
but at the time I just felt you know
like oh I was afraid to smile it's tough
when your teeth are you know you don't
love your teeth it's tough cause you're
afraid to smile and if you're not
smiling me you're not feeling you know
you start a smile that smile kind of
resonates through your body but you
don't that you know you get feeling
awkward or uncomfortable man uh you know
you don't smile and then that really can
kind of shut down the rest of your
feelings right there so that was a lot
of my a lot of my youth was like that
man you know just hating the way that I
looked for some reason I hated
everything about myself really growing
up I mean I had a ton of self-loathing
but but as I've gotten to be an adult
I've really started to get worked
through some of that you know but yeah
but I ended up getting an Invisalign man
you know I went to I talked to my
dentist about it I went in the other day
for a cleaning she'd ordered them so now
I just got them I guess that's the new
thing like just you know order something
for somebody and then you know if you
know it's like a dealership you just
they call you like a stop by you get
there and they already got you a car you
got to pay for it of course I mean I got
to pay for this deal but um but yeah I'm
wearing them you know I'm excited I
don't have them in right now but uh
after I brushed my teeth after just
coffee I'm gonna get into some huh and
when I was doing something I was always
gonna tell you guys it happened oh I did
a little manscaping you know you got to
tighten up I use it number two around
the top of the UH the happy sack and
everything my penis was starting to look
like a like a [__] wise raccoon
what a big nose you know my penis is
starting to look a little you know
almost like it like it had like it was
like it was considering things you know
it really had some whiskers around like
it was uh like it was um
Hasidic you know it really just had
those long braids on the side almost I'd
love to corner on my pubic hair at some
point I don't know if anybody does that
if there's any ladies out there you know
in in any community that do that I
wouldn't mind maybe getting some of that
done so that's where I'm at man I'm
stoked for this week we got Margaret Cho
Adam Carolla and Pete and and and some
other guests that are coming on the
podcast interviewing them tomorrow
really excited to go talk with Adam he
has me on his podcast sometimes and
Margaret Cho I've been seeing a lot of
her recently I saw her a couple times
this weekend I had dinner with John
Murray this weekend that was really
surprising
he created the real world and road rules
a lot of people don't know or dunno I
was a cast member on road rules when I
was young and I was 19 and so here I was
it was cool I mean he and I have kept in
touch over the years and he's always
been really supportive such a smart guy
it was just cool to be at a table with
him and sit there and really get to chop
it up and talk about shows these days
and just everything man he also made
that I mean he made every show like so
many reality shows I mean I can't even
name I'm probably 40 shows maybe more
but we're talking about bad [__] club
or whatever that show is it's just like
bad [__] just just being bad so
anyway that was interesting managed to
get to spend some time around that dude
what else bro I'm tired man I'm tired
bro you know I want to rest
always will always want to rest dude and
I've been watching that show disappeared
you ever seen that show it's on Hulu and
it comes on television investigative
discovery and each episode is about
somebody that went missing and then
guess what they're still missing but I
love those kind of shows man like for
some reason I love like
like those investigative discovery
murder your neighbor treasure hunter
shows that kind I can't sleep I
literally cannot fall asleep at night
unless I know that somebody really got
killed or there's a missing treasure
like those I got it's like I got to have
it man it's like my addiction dude what
else got some new movies in the mail
from the sag people la-la-land
that's her everybody says it the best
one it won a lot of awards I want to
want a lot of awards and Jackie fences I
watched fences is the one with Denzel
Washington
I watched Manchester by the sea bro whoo
man if you haven't seen Manchester by
the sea should watch it also there's a
documentary out there called dear
Zachary or letters to Zachary it's on
it's on Netflix that and Manchester by
the sea or two of that really the
saddest pieces of uh pieces of film I've
ever watched man if you want to just get
a little bit sad Bron just really get
any your feelings you know and just you
know just navigate within your sadness
and kind of feel that you know maybe
your eyes kind of spray out a little bit
get some salt water out of your system
dude that'll do it bro Wow both of those
really good Casey Affleck is amazing
dude amazing it was really really cool
to see so yeah man that was this past
weekend dude that's what's going on you
know that's kind of where I'm at you
know feeling good off the pornography
did some adult sex feeling good you know
we'll see kind of how that kind of pans
out or whatever but that's that and yeah
and that's it man just trying to stay in
gratitude man trying to just stay just
stay stay feeling blessed for the things
that I do have in my life it's tough to
do I kind of remind myself every day of
the little things that I do have that
keep me excited try not to get involved
in the negative stuff and just try and
keep you know working with the gifts
that God gave me you know you know I'm
just trying my best man life ain't easy
and I don't think it's easy for anybody
you know I don't think it's easy for
anybody so I try to remember that trying
to anyway I mean every day is a battle
you know every every moment is a battle
you know just trying to put things in
place that help me get through the
battles and not even to win I just want
I just want to come out even I want
everybody to come out even am I trying
to beat anybody you know I'm just trying
to be I'm just trying to stay the best I
can with myself man that's where I'm at
I did Coco Diaz his podcast Joey Diaz I
was on the Church of what's happening
now the other day bro that's good man
getting in there with a little least
syat dude the frickin high hamster Lisa
at that guy we had a blast man we went
deep told some stories about I was you
know I was a bed-wetter
I was a bed-wetter most of my life we
got into that so if you want to check
that out you can check it out on Joey
Diaz his podcast Churchill what's
happening now if you have any thoughts
or questions or anything about you want
to ask me or get at me man throw it at
me you know we're gonna get better we're
gonna get some video I don't know if
doing a podcast is for me like this you
know I really like being a guest I
really like being a guest on people's
podcast but I don't know if I should
have my own podcast because sometimes I
don't know if I have enough really to
talk about you know mm-hmm
you know I'm just really still trying to
decide some of my point of views on
things you know I don't really know what
makes me mad you know mainstream media
makes me mad that's for sure dude I'm so
sick of them bruh damn if anybody still
believes the news you're out of your
brain make your own choices make your
own choices but uh be good to yourselves
man be good to yourselves cuz cuz it
starts there you know be good to
yourselves because you probably deserve
it you probably deserve it and that's it
man those are the dates dude coming up
February 26 through 29th purge Enya
Beach at the funny bone I'll be at the
Chicago improv in Schaumburg February
2nd through 4th sorry that's January
26th through 29th in Virginia Beach
Chicago February
2nd through the 4th Denver Comedy worked
South February 23rd through 26th and
that's it if you want to grab some bra
here I got some brush shirts and lady
brush shirts online Theo von calm so I
store all my tour dates are at the
Viacom slash tour and that's it man
love you guys bro be good to yourself
let's listen a little bit more bro on
the way out Weedon boy huh Wiz Khalifa
right there BAM brothers can smoke
campaign they good at it man
they should have a national like a weed
smoke and lead where people just get
together on teams and get as high as
they can and after like five minutes
whoever is still able to like answer a
couple of math problems they win I would
go with probably brothers and Russians
I'll go with black men and Russians
Russians seem like they could get pretty
lit but still man as well you guys be
good man this is just past week and I'll
see you guys uh next Monday all right
you good to yourselves men have a great
week